I mean this time yesterday we were
talking about the fact that it's
actually the data that we received
yesterday it was a sobering set of data
in itself again today these figures are
even higher but we should say that
actually this is in the range that is
expected we know that things are going
to get worse before they get better the
lockdown measures that are currently in
place it's going to take a good couple
of weeks before we do feel the effects
of those but we have now had more of a
regional breakdown of exactly how that
the figures are looking for the whole of
the picture across the UK the total
number of deaths we know has increased
by 563 our pond up to in total two
thousand three hundred and fifty-two 31
percent higher than the figures that we
had for yesterday when we're talking
about confirmed positive cases of Cove
at 19 as well that now has increased to
twenty nine thousand four hundred and
seventy four cases in the UK up by more
than four thousand to put that in
perspective for you yesterday we were
talking about how it was significant
that it was up by three thousand this
latest set of data it now has increased
by more than four thousand and breaking
it down into regions for Scotland we
know the total number of deaths now has
reached 76 an increase of 16 further
deaths confirmed cases they are now up
to 29 thousand four hundred and seventy
four up sorry no they are now converted
to two thousand three hundred and ten up
by three hundred and seventeen on the
previous day and if we look in more
depth at Wales as well the total number
of deaths for Wales is now 98 an
increase of 29 and if you compare that
actually to the set of data that we had
this time yesterday
the death rate had increased by there'd
been a further seven deaths and now we
know that there have been an increase of
29 deaths so a significant rise I think
what will be interesting is how these
figures are interpreted when we see the
Downing Street press are a little later
today we know of course at that presser
yesterday they were talking about seeing
this slight plateau in the the infection
rates and whether or not that could be
interpreted really as green shoots that
actually we were seeing the in fact
rates slowing slightly an increase in
the UK cases of more than four thousand
in the last 24 hours it will be
interesting to see whether or not they
can still call that a plateau or whether
or not they feel that certainly the the
infection rates are slowing so I think
we'll watch out for the Downing Street
pressure a little later today to see how
these figures are actually interpreted